this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm going to start so my name is Marion
souffle I'm with the New York State IPM
program I work with vegetables including
hemp the last two years I've been doing
a pest survey in hemp both insects as
well as diseases and we're going to
present some of the main insect pests
that we have found and then Heather's
going to introduce herself and then
we're going to kind of tag team this so
we're going to pass the mic back and
forth
thanks Marion as Chris said I'm Heather
grab I'm in the school of Integrative
plant Sciences Marion sampling work has
focused a lot I'm for many many of your
Farms she's been out to visit for
cannabinoids sampling a lot of my
sampling has focused more on the
industrial side of him so thinking more
about the Grain and fiber Market classes
we do have also a handout today we're
going to walk through some of these
pests and the kinds of damage that we're
seeing with those I would encourage you
to migrate over to the table we have a
QR code posted there that you can scan
that will take you directly to this
sheet but we are also going to shorten
up our talk a little bit today so we'll
only speak for about 10 minutes before
we pass it over to Judson Reed who's
going to talk a little bit about soils
and high tunnels and then we'll have an
opportunity as we love to do it these
field days for you to get out and walk
through the plants and we will work with
you to help identify some of these pests
is that we are seeing in the high tunnel
here as well as over in the grow Dome
today so relative to what we've heard
about already today in terms of weeds
and diseases there's pretty good news on
the entomological front so we see a wide
diversity of different insects showing
up in hemp but for the most part they're
all of relatively low concern many of
these are insect pests that we're
familiar with in other cropping systems
which is important to think about when
we're managing diverse Farms or thinking
about crops that are grown after or
adjacent to hemp size so a lot of the
pests that we're going to think about
today here are ones that you would be
familiar with from other crops like
tarnish plant bugs or Japanese beetles
many cups of corn are also showing up in
hemp very regularly however we don't
tend to see very high levels of damage I
know another really important
consideration is the other talks
highlighted today is that there are very
few products that are registered as
treatment options for pests that's not
you know unique that's the case with
weeds also so of course scouting and
preventative management with Biologicals
is very important we see big differences
in past pressure across different Market
classes so hemp that has grown for grain
and fiber versus hemp that's grown for
cannabinoids and especially in different
growing environments some of which
you'll see today between our field
trials that we'll visit later this
afternoon the high tunnels here and then
in the grow Dome you'll see different
levels of pest pressure which are often
higher in protected culture environments
like greenhouses where environmental
conditions can be more optimal for rapid
growth of pests like aphids spider mites
and thrifts and Justin will talk a
little bit more at his talk this
afternoon about some biological control
strategies
patents so I'm going to start off with
talking about just a few of the packets
that are on the oh actually sorry we're
going to talk first really briefly about
scouting so I'm going to pass it over to
Marion to key you in on some best
practices for scouting in your process
I just hit something hopefully I still
want
um so I wanted to briefly talk about
scouting when
if you're out there looking at your hemp
ideally you're going to go out there at
least once a week when you're out there
doing other things in your hemp you're
out there anyway but what we do is
usually go out and Scout weekly
and you want to go through all your
Fields all your different plantings
looking for any insect or disease pests
you want to look at the plants select 10
random spots that's usually our
recommendation look at the entire plant
look at the flower look at the leaves
the upper surface the lower surface of
the leaf there might be insects
underneath usually if you just walk by
you might not see spider mites starting
on the lower part of the plant
underneath so you really want to make
sure you look at the entire plant look
at the stems there might be boring
insects that are getting into the stem
if the plant isn't looking the
healthiest you might even want to look
down into the roots so that's a really
quick way to scout but go out there
frequently and look at the entire plant
[Music]
all right so what should you be looking
for oftentimes uh you will see the
insects more frequently than the damage
so I'm going to walk through some of the
ones that we're seeing frequently that
we've highlighted on our sheet there one
that came up really frequently this
season with the hot dry weather is four
lined plant bug so that is a
characteristic yellow green and black
striped insect that causes piercing
thank you that causes piercing sucking
damage on the leaves and so Marion's
walking around with an example of that
really characteristic eating damage
that's associated with this pests
fortunately populations of this pest
tend to decline really dramatically
around June so we're most concerned
about this test during hot dry seasons
and especially early in the season
during Finance establishment the next
test on our list is relative slidespread
very broad Host range the tarnished
plant bug so another true bug pest it's
feeding on developing plant tissues
particularly on the developing leaves
and the developing flower tissue so I've
seen a lot more of this also with the
dry weather this year it causes a sort
of Swiss cheese type feeding on the
leaves and Marion actually has some real
plant samples that she's going to pass
around of what this damage looks like so
because the damage is happening as those
leaves are developing and expanding you
won't see the plant buds feeding on the
leaves itself you'll see the evidence of
that damage showing up after those
leaves have fully expanded this is also
a pest that is going to be feeding on
developing flower tissue and potentially
maybe also causing some impacts in Grain
production system so that so that loves
to feed on developing seeds so those of
you who are producers of veg and fruit
crops will be familiar with this past
managing some of the weedy alternative
hosts is a great strategy for dealing
with this
the next one up is one that almost
everyone will have seen independent of
the systems unless you are fully in a
controlled environment system and that's
Japanese beetles they are large beetles
that have an aggregating feeding
Behavior the adults are feeding on the
leaves they'll often also be up in the
flowers so we get a lot of reports from
Growers who are seeing these beetles but
fortunately we do not tend to see high
levels of damage perhaps with the
exception of some of our green cultivars
that have very low levels of cannabinoid
expression which speaks to the potential
for cannabinoids foreign
to be having some action against
herbivorous pests George stack who's a
PhD student working with Larry smart has
some experiments going on looking at the
relationship between test damage levels
and cannabinoid expressions in hemp and
so I encourage you all to look out for
his results that will be coming out soon
but overall we're seeing you know
relatively low concern in terms of
Japanese beetles even though they are a
relatively apparent past that tends to
aggregate a lot so our last test that
I'm going to share with you before I
pass it over to Marion zukul so she's
showing you right now some examples of
Japanese beetles and the feeding damage
that they cause on leaves
is the flea beetles flea beetles are
another pass that we tend to see much
more commonly in hot dry weather when
their alternative weedy hosts are less
preferred or even less available in the
environment they tend to cause sort of a
shotgun style irregular getting damage
on leaves we're mostly seeing red-headed
flea beetles showing up in our hemp
fields and again these are a relatively
low concern pests
with the Inception of early stand
establishment where heavy levels of
feeding could potentially cause issues
so all of the four pests that I shared
with you just now are ones that you
should be most concerned about in
outdoor cultivation systems I'm going to
pass it over to Marion she's going to
talk about a few more pests that you'll
find in outdoor production systems and
then also highlight a view that you can
see in more protected culture
[Music]
foreign
Heather's still going around with the
red-headed flea Beetle I'm sorry I
should have made a lot more samples It's
a larger crowd than we anticipated which
is good
um but so red-headed flea Beetle adults
and damage just noticed the difference
between the size of the damage the
Japanese beetle much larger holes
um the red-headed flea bit also making
holes in the tarnished plant bug
cleaner holes with more of a lighter
um
surround the area surrounding the hole
is a little paler in color all right I'm
going to talk about the potato Leaf
Hopper and when Heather gets back
she can pass around the picture I think
hopefully people are familiar with the
um potato Leaf Hopper kind of a
wedge-shaped lime green both the nymph
as well as the adult they'll both be a
pest in hemp um usually in fields that
are close to Alfalfa they're coming in
from the alfalfa
they'll cause what's termed Hopper burn
which on the image you'll see
um the tips of the leaf are starting to
turn yellow eventually they will Wilt
and turn brown if you have a very severe
Leaf Hopper population some of the
control measures is trying not to plant
your hemp near a potential another crop
like Alfalfa that could serve as a host
where they're coming in from
if red clover is a host as well
so the next one is two spotted spider
mite which um Heather's passing around
this is the one that we often see on the
underside of leaves near the bottom of
the plant
um it's a Mite so it'll have eight legs
and two spotted because it has those two
big black spots on either side not all
of them will have that if they've just
malted they're probably not going to
look like that they'll be very
translucent but the majority of the ones
you see are going to look like that and
the damage is very similar to thrips
damage she does have a picture on there
for damage but we also have thrips
damaged leaves they're extremely similar
I have not seen any this year in hemp
which kind of surprises me because it's
been such a hot dry year which usually
promotes the two spotted spider mite
they'll also cause webbing on the plant
if you get a severe enough population
you'll find like little silk webbing and
they'll kind of tie some of the leaves
together
so and judson's going to talk about bio
control of two-spotted spider mite in
the session later this afternoon I was
just told we're getting tight on time so
this is the Cannabis aphid uh fairly
distinct one if you know aphids they
have like these um this aphid has two
dark lines running the length of the
body so if you have cannabis aphid
that's the primary aphid that's going to
get into your hemp uh fairly easy to
recognize
since we're tight on time I'm going to
quickly get into the um oh I think I
skipped corn bore I'm sorry I'm earworm
that was the one that I skipped her ear
worm
as the name implies it's a pest of corn
so if you're planting close to Corn you
might get corn ear worm into your hemp
as well they lay their eggs in the
flower buds or on the leaves but then
the larvae will hatch and make their way
into the flower buds so you'll have
damage in the flower Bud if we have so
Heather's passing out the larvae of the
Corn ear worm so you can see what the
larvae look like
one thing we don't have any thresholds
for corn earworm in hemp
but you can put traps out which we use
in sweet corn to monitor the population
so you'd put a trap out near your hemp
field and see if you have any corn
earworm present if you do you might want
to start checking your flower buds see
if there's any larvae getting in there
and if you want to see adult corn
earworm when Heather gets back she can
pass out the adult corn earworm so you
know what you're looking for in those
traps and the final ones that I'm going
to quickly go over are the boring
insects we have both the European corn
borer as well as the common stock for
they lay their eggs on the hemp but then
they bore right into it so you're not
going to see a lot of damage outside
what you're going to find is an entrance
hole but usually what you're going to
find is just a broken
tip or stock of the hemp plant and when
you peel it back you're going to find
the larvae probably more of a problem in
some of the fiber hemp rather than the
cannabinoid hemp just because they have
a thinner
stock and they're more likely going to
snap whereas the the real thick CBD hemp
can withstand some of that boring
pressure it actually sometimes causes it
to Branch out more so some people
actually don't mind having a bore in
their CBD hemp
I will encourage everyone after you get
a chance to come through and Scout
through the plants or chat with us to
please come up and check out any of
these samples of different pest damage
that we have we also do want to
highlight that particularly in outdoor
cultivation you will see a really high
abundance of beneficials which we've
highlighted a few of lace wings as well
as lady beetles we do not recommend that
you purchase and
apply those in outdoor environments Judd
will surely talk about bio control
Solutions in his talk this afternoon
that would be more appropriate for
indoor cultivation but there's many
beneficials out there including
ingrained in fiber cultivation are
really high abundance of pollinators
that are utilizing all of the pollen
that is produced by male plants so also
supporting a beneficial insect
population that we want to be aware of
when we're thinking about management
strategies or broadly about biodiversity
Management on our arms so I think we
will leave it for there and we'll pass
over to Judson Reed who is coming to us
from Harvest New York and we'll talk
about soil management
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu